pourquoi ce projet pourquoi je suis
freelance
pourquoi je crée mon restaurant pourquoi
je décide de me reconvertir pour devenir
sophrologue
pourquoi je décide de développer mon
blog où ma chaîne youtube
pourquoi je décide de tout plaquer pour
prendre la responsabilité d'une
association
pourquoi je décide de tout quitter pour
lancer un site e-commerce
alors pourquoi ce projet c'est la
question qui m'anime depuis très
longtemps maintenant c'est une question
qui semble évidente mais moi pendant
très très longtemps je me suis pas du
tout posé cette question
alors quand j'étais en primaire je me
posais pas évidemment pas beaucoup la
question pourquoi est ce que je suis en
primaire j'aimais bien y aller pour
jouer au foot à la récré jamais bien les
cols du tour aimer l'école quand j'étais
au collège je ne me faisais pas non plus
la question pourquoi est ce que je fais
des maths pourquoi je fais du français
ou pourquoi je suis collégiens j'y
allais parce que ma maman me disait que
c'était très important alors au lycée ça
a commencé à venir
là je me suis dit pourquoi je vais faire
un bac es tu as première fois de ma vie
que j'ai réfléchi un petit peu à cette
question pourquoi ce projet la réponse
était pas terrible
j'ai décidé de faire un bac es parce que
c'était la seule orientation où il n'y
avait pas de physique chimie et comme
j'avais jamais eu plus de deux sur 20 à
un contrôle de physique chimie
je me suis dit c'est pour moi ce que
j'ai fait à ce moment là c'est que j'ai
pas vraiment répondu à la question
pourquoi ce projet j'ai fait ce qu'on
appelle un choix par défaut
on le verra plus tard les choix par
défaut c'est rarement des bons choix
alors j'ai continué en toujours dans
cette logique de ne pas vraiment
m'interroger autour de la question
pourquoi ce projet je suis arrivé en
école de commerce et à ce moment là il
fallait valider le diplôme et pour
valider le diplôme il fallait créer une
entreprise
c'est pour ça qu'à 20 ans j'ai créé ma
première boîte
pourquoi je les crée encore une fois ont
validé mon diplôme tp à nouveau un choix
par défaut
la société elle n'a pas eu un grand
avenir
j'avais un associé et il est parti au
bout de deux semaines deux semaines quoi
s'était pas beaucoup et puis six mois
plus tard on avait réalisé un chiffre
d'affaires de 16 euros et j'ai décidé
d'arrêter cette société donc à nouveau
je me suis pris en pleine face que les
choix par défaut
c'était pas les meilleures avec ce jeu
surtout avec les 16 euros de chiffre
d'affaires
je me souviens que j'ai invité ma mère
au cinéma ça faisait deux places 2
places de cinéma et j'ai continué ma
route
alors maintenant on est il ya quatre ans
et là je me dis bon ça commence à bien
faire cette histoire faut que je lance
un nouveau projet mais cette fois ça
doit pas être un choix par défaut
donc je m'interroge sur ce que j'aime
vraiment et là j'ai eu une idée j'ai
enfin une idée là je sais que c'est la
bonne
je parte simplement de ce que j'aime
faire il se trouve que j'aime enseigner
j'aime transmettre fait des années que
je donne des cours sous des formes très
différentes
je donne des cours de maths à des
collégiens je donne des cours d'économie
à des lycéens et à chaque fois j'aime ça
à chaque fois j'aime transmettre
je me retrouve même un moment dans une
association qui vient en aide à des
jeunes qui sont déscolarisés
je me fais insulter par un des jeunes
dès mon premier coup il sort un couteau
mais j'aime bien
j'aime bien ça va j'aime transmettre jeu
j'affronte donc je me dis c'est sûr là
ça va marcher
qu'est ce que je fais pas je crée un
site de cours sur internet et je pensais
avoir répondu à cette question pourquoi
ce projet je pensais qu'en qu'en
choisissant une idée que j'aime
pour la première fois c'était sûr que ça
allait fonctionner sa fille
le patron c'est dur c'est dur c'est dur
c'est dur pendant plusieurs années c'est
vraiment dur je me lève tous les matins
super tôt je me lève à 7h je bosse je
bosse je bosse je bosse je prends une
petite pause pour déjeuner je bosse
pendant que je déjeune je reprends la
pmi l'après midi je continue de bosser
j'ai pas de copine je vois plus trop ma
famille j'ai arrêté le sport et plus de
vacances je bosse vous dit c'est sûr que
ça va fonctionner concrètement j'ai une
vie horrible pendant plusieurs années et
ça marche pas je ne comprends pas
pourquoi ça marche pas j'étais certain
qu'en mettant poser cette question
pourquoi ce projet et en ayant trouvé
une idée que j'aime ça allait
fonctionner on a plein de galère on est
même au moment le moment où j'ai
commencé à comprendre qu'il fallait
aller plus loin dans la réflexion c'est
quand on a été attaqué en justice par un
dessin animé que je mets beaucoup quand
j'étais petit dessin animé qui m'a
attaqué parce que le nom de notre
société
à l'époque était similaire au nom d'un
des personnages de dessins animés
je commence à je commence à déprimer
on est en août 2016 je suis au plus mal
et je suis pas le seul à être au plus
mal ma grand mère qui à 94 ans est parti
en vacances à chypre
et elle tombe malade et comme ma grand
mère m'a en partie élevé bien évidemment
je suis juste très sensible à ce qui lui
arrive
je prends un billet d'avion je fonce à
chypre qui est déjà là
chypre dans la salle une personne bon tu
as tous tu as une bonne expérience je
vais te raconter la mienne j'arrive à
shief ma grand mère est à l'hôpital
heureusement ça va plutôt bien
elle se rétablit ya un problème avec
l'assurance qui veut pas prendre en
charge les frais d'hôpitaux comme ma
grand mère à 94 ans vers qui est ce
qu'on se retourne vers moi et policiers
arrivent parle pas très bien anglais je
parle pas du tout chypriote
ils me prennent mon passeport je me
retrouve à chypre sans passeport avec ma
grand mère il va mieux heureusement mais
qui dort quand même dix heures par jour
et par internet
j'ai pas de téléphone j'ai plus de
passeport je me retrouve seul pendant
une semaine à chypre j'ai rien à faire
je veux plus bosser mon rythme classique
que je maintenais comme un dingue
depuis le début a bossé bossé bossé ben
ils iront plus je peux plus le tenir et
ça ça a été la chance de ma vie
durant cette semaine à chypre j'ai
compris ce qui m'arrivait j'ai enfin
compris ce que c'était qu'entreprendre
j'ai compris qu'il fallait aller
beaucoup plus loin que la question
pourquoi ce projet qu'il fallait se
demander qu'est ce qui m'anime vraiment
dans ce projet qu'est ce que j'aime
faire avec qui j'ai envie de le faire
quelles relations j'ai envie d'avoir
avec les gens avec qui je fais ce projet
pour qui est ce que je le fais à quoi ça
ressemble dans deux ans dans quatre ans
dans six ans qu'est-ce que j'en retire
moi personnellement ces questions elles
peuvent sembler simple moi je me léser
tu es j'avais posé au final j'étais
resté en surface
ce voyage à chypre il m'a rappelé
l'importance de prendre du recul
il m'a rappelé l'importance
indispensable de se poser les vraies
questions
je suis rentré j'ai re
mon équipe et on a complètement
transformé ce qu'on faisait on est
reparti à zéro on a tout refait depuis
le début en 2016 on a formé 50 personnes
et là on atteint le cap des 5000 alors
c'est pas du tout facile non plus on a
encore plein de galère plein plein plein
de galère mais au moins maintenant je
sais pourquoi je fais ce projet je sais
que je le fais parce que je veux aider
des gens à entreprendre aujourd'hui les
gens que je forme c'est plus des
collégiens qui ont besoin des dents
maths c'est des créateurs d'entreprise
ce et des porteurs de projet c'est des
personnes qui sont free lance qui sont
mon thérapeute qui sont haïs commerçants
qui sont blogueurs et je sais que dans
les coachings qu'on distribue le plus
important c'est cette question pourquoi
ce projet j'ai réalisé au fond que ces
questions on n'a pas l'habitude de se
les poser la vérité c'est qu'à l'école
on a un programme donc les choses sont
assez simples
on commence l'année et on sait quel est
le programme de physique chimie on sait
quel est le programme de maths on sait
ce qui nous attend
on connaît même al avance la date des
épreuves du baccalauréat
donc tout ça est assez planifiées alors
que quand on dit un entrepreneur c'est
le chaos
c'est tous les jours les montagnes
russes tous les jours il ya un truc qui
explose tous les jours et un truc qui
pète et si on n'a pas pris le temps de
se poser les questions pourquoi je fais
ce projet et toutes les questions qui en
découle évidemment on fait les mauvais
choix on peut pas tenir
on se fatigue on s'épuise on n'arrive
plus à avancer
alors ce que j'aimerais vous proposez
c'est que la prochaine fois que vous
rencontrez quelqu'un qui est
entrepreneur qui est porte
le projet qui a envie de faire quelque
chose posez-lui ces questions-là pas
pour décourager loin de la paix non plus
pour lui prendre la tête et le faire se
noyer dans un verre d'eau mais
profondément pour l'aider à savoir ce
qu'ils valent à motiver je suis un
partisan du long terme
je suis un partisan du temps long je
sais qu'on nous bassine les oreilles
avec la génération y z
ab je sais plus laquelle en nous disant
qu'on est des slasher qu'on ait des gens
qui changent le projet aussi vite que je
suis que s'il ya quelque chose qui
fonctionne pas et bah c'est pas grave on
s'en fiche il suffit de prendre une
autre idée de prendre un autre secteur
de prendre un autre domaine mon approche
est radicalement différente ce qui m'a
fait tenir durant ces années où c'était
difficile c'est que je savais que la
pédagogie
j'aimais ça j'avais juste pas compris
que derrière la question pourquoi ce
projet il y avait beaucoup d'autres
questions
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]